our entire universe literally shut down
it's an industry worth 10.8 billion
pounds a year to the uk economy
but the lockdown has caused arts venues
to close events to be cancelled
and left thousands of jobs at risk it
was sort of like falling off a cliff
artists have taken to the streets to
demand more help in the crisis
and the government has promised a 1.57
billion pound rescue fund
but for some performers there are missed
opportunities that simply cannot be
replaced
i allowed myself to be pretty depressed
i think everybody's just trying to do
the best that they can right now
it's very tricky to see how a lot of
musicians
can carry on having sustainable careers
what is the point in anything without
art and laughter and joy
hi i'm eliza shad i'm a musician and a
songwriter
based in the uk i feel like 2020
felt like my year i
guess i knew
right from the start
nothing you could say or i
do is ever gonna penetrate my heart
um i really felt like everything had
started coming together
um i had a new record that came out in
january that i was really proud of and
it's doing really well with
uh streaming and i also had
a uk tour booked with our biggest ever
headline tour and the culmination of
which was to play here at scala
this job and this career is often about
momentum
and then i had it
actually i got ill um during the tour
and
i spoke to a doctor they said it wasn't
covered we carried on touring
um and the next day i just couldn't sing
i was coughing so much
and then the next day the government
said if you're coughing then you have to
stay home for two weeks
so the whole rest of the tour got
cancelled all the festivals
cancelled and i've been home
basically ever since like the rest of
the country
on average musicians have lost 11 300
pounds from cancelled gigs since march
2020
many have had to find new ways of
performing live i actually
put on a live stream show with the
supports who are due to play with me
here at scala on the day that scarlet
was supposed to happen
um just as a way of thanking the
audience who would you to come and the
supports as well who
you know had been looking forward to it
and and it was so fun that i've done it
every week since
so i think i've done 35
weekly live streams since then they're
just three little things i've tried out
new
songs i've it's been quite an
interesting document
i think of
my temperament week by week because
sometimes i've had a very productive
week
and it's a very cheery live stream and
sometimes i'm just inconsolable
about the state of the music industry
and it's quite dark
it's very tricky to see how a lot of
musicians
can carry on having sustainable careers
everyone i know is in so much trouble
so many people are going to have to find
other work and so many albums aren't
going to get made
and especially so many kind of
marginalized voices who don't
receive the support that maybe richer
musicians do
that's going to have a detrimental
effect on on
the music that we produce and the
incredible industry that we're
lucky and proud to have enjoyed so far
[Music]
my name is lily phillips and i'm a new
stand-up comedian everybody it's lily
village
my 2020 this year was supposed to be
a lead up to the edinburgh fringe
festival
hey guys i'm lilly as you're starting
out as a new comedian
one of the milestones is creating an
hour-length
show i was selected for the pleasants
reserve
they nurture you to develop your hour
and then perform at the end of the
fringe
and yeah hopefully i would have got
opportunities from that
that was just kind of tunnel vision just
all i was thinking about all the time hi
everyone
i'm most probably not very fun to be
around
you can ask my boyfriend that it was it
was upsetting because
i think i'd finally found something that
i definitely wanted to do
i was on the way and to hopefully making
a career out of it and then it all
stopped and
it was hard to know where to turn really
78 of comedy venues are facing closure
in the next year
many comics have turned to online videos
and podcasts
but nothing is quite the same as a live
performance i just did a couple of
outdoor gigs
um in what i can only describe as a
thunderstorm
and normally before any of this had
happened
we would cancel we would say this is not
a pleasant experience and it's not worth
it
in terms of listening to these jokes but
now everyone just stays nobody left even
though
like it was quite risky and like i think
the tent was about to fall down but they
just stayed anyway because we're just
desperate
i've been lily phillips you guys have
been great have a great night
what is the point in anything without
like art and laughter and
joy what what is the point why why are
we all fighting for anything if we're
not gonna
you know strive to have a nice time and
enjoy our lives
and that's what art is you know that's
what it's all about
even without a pandemic making a career
for yourself in the arts
is a challenge and for recent graduates
it's become more difficult than ever to
find work
these students are rehearsing for a
socially distanced play
they rehearse in masks and some of the
cast have even moved in with each other
and form bubbles
i think it's just adapting i've been
really enjoying it though to be fair
like i don't think it's taken away from
the experience if anything it's made it
more of a challenge for sure but i think
the reward is going to be so much
greater
when we're able to get up in a space and
actually perform
um i think everybody's just trying to do
the best that they can right now
and that's okay everything's a bit
slower than it used to be
but that doesn't have to entirely be a
bad thing
an actor's career is unsaid but um
it's exciting and i think especially
with these
um changes to the world i think
it's it sort of takes off the burden out
of us a little bit to
feel a bit more relaxed look no one is
certain anymore and
no one knows what's going to happen we
don't know what's going to be at the end
of the tunnel do you know what i mean so
we're all in the same boat really and i
think that's given me a bit of relief
between march and october 2020 there
were nearly 7
500 redundancies in theater and live
events
uh hi there i'm victor leo i am a
theater director
uh what was supposed to happen to me in
2020 um
i had a job i was
i was on tom morris's
new production of some of ice with
the great mark rylance two of my heroes
i had those
posts that possibly
could have led to other jobs and because
of the pandemic
our entire universe halted our entire
universe
literally shut down i started exploring
a more a composite form
of of a live theater performance
using film using camera and the internet
which is kind of exciting eat it fast
technology allowed me to create
to use to discover and explore
uh we started reading it just flat
there's the script
hello who might i be talking to
hello it's me and then we added
physical reality and we added some
virtual blocking and
it was really cool like it's like
building blocks of
you're building your own set of rules
you're creating your own set of rules
rather in this new form theater artists
and artists in general have always
found new ways to create and i think
it's
it's it's not going to be any different
hi i'm ella taylor pronouns they them
i'm
a freelance classical soprano and i'm an
alumni of the national opera studio
which is where we are right now
i'd kind of envisioned 2020 as like
being my year i was supposed to go to
glasgow to sing with scottish oprah i
was supposed to
come then come back down to london um
and work with
the orchestra of english national opera
at cadogan hall as well
um and we were supposed to just do
lots of auditions for very important
people
you know opera houses agents so instead
of my
supposed jam pack schedule for 2020
i am i took a beat i allowed myself
to be pretty depressed about the whole
situation which
i think is fair enough i was lucky
because i was still a young artist
at the national opera studio um they
organized a load of um coachings
for us all via the magic of zoom
and i can play some stuff if it helps
but it obviously will be off
rhythmically
helps to play chords between i can do
that
it basically involved me
stacking up a lot of books on my dining
room table
to make sure that my laptop was head
height
and what because i have to stand up to
sing we
want we
want we
i do think freelancers have been
overlooked
in the world that we live in uh
freelancers who
experience racism disabled freelancers
queer freelancers are
fall through the cracks even more
because employment was
kind of scarce enough as it was
um and now there's no employment so it
just makes it even more difficult
the lockdown has taken its toll on
performers from across the arts
more than a third of musicians have
considered quitting the industry
and even more comedians have thought
about the same thing
i'd definitely be lying if i said that i
hadn't thought about leaving the
industry
more than a few times most musicians
have gotten to where they are by being
temeritus and not ever giving up
let me quote um churchill
he said never let a good crisis go to
waste
so this is actually an opportunity for
us
it never crossed my mind um
so i guess i'm just gonna keep going
my hopes for the future would be to
hopefully continue to be the most
authentic
version of myself and of the artist that
i
am and to have a lot of fun
singing some real cool stuff